皆さん恐怖症っていうものをご存知でしょうか
何何恐怖症っていうのがあるんですけどもなんと国枝見ながら例えば
教祖交付
自分が嫌になる今日も松降ちが教書
違うな元たちが高所本書で高所恐怖症とか高いところにいると恐怖を感じる暗所恐怖症
とかある暗いところだった曲を感じとか何何恐怖症っていうやつがあるんですけど
マーケットに入れて調べてたんですけどもその恐怖症鉄なんとなんと
ですねびっくり副手何何教書っていうのはすごい色々あったね中にはなんか本当に版て
わかんない恐怖症とかえってをも今日書とか末端でちょっとそれはね僕が見つけた長所
めだかのなぜかこれと思ったらちょっと何個か皆さんに紹介してあげようと思いますで
は行こう
ぴょんまずこれはすごいと思った信連です教科書
花に対する恐怖症
花は脅威ではないと理解しているにもかかわらず見たり考えたりすることに強い馬も
感じ
他の見るだけでもう変調を感じてしまうというねなぜかねとびっくりした恐怖症の一つ
でした
次黄色教科書黄色のものに恐怖を感じる極端な場合は黄色という言葉を聞いた時でも
強い不安を立てる者は之屋1種黄色恐怖症だよ
家族ピーナツバター教授所ピーナッツまだうわーん
くっつきが恐れる教書 t 県立的なように思えるが実際に存在しますある方は
ピーナッツパターンそばにある度に来ず想像してしまい
ように汗が噴き出して体が震えだしうわがザラザラして不快になる級だ
ピーナツバターか ana 京都松アナボコッとしているのはね気持ち悪い怖いと
感じる今日でございます
ポエム恐怖症詩を読んだり書いたりすることに対して不安を覚える相手に周囲を真似て
もその意味が完全に理解できてないのではないかという不安が増大して曲知ったケース
が多い
湖今日部署をその新生物が生息しているのではないか吸い込まれてしまうのではないか
といった不安から湖を見ることを変えることにとして強い今日ボーイ啄木さんこれです
泉というかな海の底とか海の底もめっちゃ桑町深いところすっごい9
密に巨匠と言う海の底とがも恐怖症です集合体恐怖症
鳥肌イチゴの粒相良な卵昆虫の音等の密集しているものに対し以上のまでの恐怖感で
右腕が不快感などが出る症状回さない手はないですよねカエルの卵のぐじゃぐじゃって
言うともう
ああああああああ
3あご今日部署二重顎無垢な顎割れたあこだとへの恐怖
par
ガーッと1いかがだったでしょうか様々な恐怖症があるわけなんですよ
あと僕はですねオフィスを恐怖症ですかの実際にあるらしいんですけども
およそを見るとなんかあんまりなゲソ嫌いなんですよねその切ってるんだよね切断され
てる感がを感じるただ実際ねこの恐怖症っていう症状がある人しかわからないんですよ
ねどれだけか
は行ってきたなんか色々な競争があるんですけれども皆さんのもし私はこの局所だよっ
て人がいたらコメント欄で教えてください
じゃあなぁ
ん
んをっ
おっん
うまいん
うまいぞ